the man behind Hittle so it speaks  Taylor Swift and Tom Hiddleston shocked  the world when they debuted their  relationship and since then the two have  been traveling the globe together so  much so that some have speculated  they're actually pulling off some kind  of elaborate publicity stunt or even  shooting a lemonade style music video  but Thursday Tom got an Emmy nomination  and as part of an interview about it he  was asked about Taylor here's what he  told The Hollywood Reporter quote the  truth is that Taylor Swift and I are  together and we're very happy that's the  truth it's not a publicity stunt Tom  making things 100% clear the actor is  currently in Australia filming for tour  three and we got a wonder if Taylor was  sitting right there when he took that  phone call she's been in asti land with  him for several days